[Musique]
roberto
oui oui je vais bien merci beaucoup
de m'avoir accordé cette interview tout va
bien te souviens-tu de ce que tu as fait ce que
tu as fait avec ta famille il y a 20 ans
bien sûr
regrettes-tu quelque chose
non
es-tu toujours en colère contre euh la société
je  Je n'ai jamais été en colère contre la
société tout ce que tu penses de moi est
déformé
non je demande juste oh non tu vois ce que
je dis mais tu vois tu as toute une
opinion mondiale
et cette opinion mondiale est faite
avec des ordures
j'ai fait quelque chose pour être ici non non non non non non non non c'est ce qu'ils te vendent j'avais des amis qui ont fait certaines choses
oh oui mais toi tu sais que tu portes l'
esprit oh j'étais l'esprit qui était
j'étais le cerveau hein  comment pouvez-vous condamner
quelqu'un pour ça
j'ai 20 ans menotté parce que vous
pensez
que j'ai dit à quelqu'un de faire quelque chose mais
elle a aussi pris des vies non
non non non je ne suis pas si stupide
alors comment appelez-vous cette
dispense de Dieu
alors  que pensez-vous que vous êtes
je suis je suis un témoin
c'est comme si ce
dieu est la vie la vie est tout
dieu est tout
alors nous nous réunissons en famille comme une unité
et nous chantons tous
du fond du cœur avez-vous encore des
contacts avec votre famille, bien sûr, leur
écrivez-vous, nous vous écrivons pour
quoi faire  écris on sait tous les mêmes
choses tu sais est-
ce qu'ils viennent te voir il n'y a rien
à venir me voir ils se regardent dans le
miroir
donc tu avoues que tu étais une sorte de
guide pour la famille un de ma famille donc
tu mets  ma famille je connaissais la
nana peut-être six mois
trois mois linda pourrait te sauver et je la
connaissais depuis deux semaines
maintenant tu vas dire que je rencontrerais une
femme pendant deux semaines et je vais lui dire d'
aller tuer sept personnes
allez  mec je veux dire où est ton
intellect mec n'as-tu pas de logique
ou d'équilibre dans ton propre cerveau
même si
j'ai pu
et je contrôle la dispense de
cela ne veut pas dire que je l'ai fait
je n'ai pas enfreint la loi de l'homme
parce que  Je comprends la loi de l'homme si
quelqu'un te fait du mal,
il commence à ne pas t'aimer
et rat  elle que de se regarder dans le miroir et d'
admettre ses torts à eux-mêmes, puis
ils blâment quelqu'un quelqu'un doit être
dangereux
quelqu'un doit être mauvais
alors maintenant je dois être le méchant et
le gars dangereux
qu'est-ce que c'est vraiment idiot je suis  un petit
vieux je ne suis pas vraiment dangereux du tout
la seule chose qui est dangereuse chez moi
c'est que je dis la vérité et j'en
sais beaucoup
j'en sais beaucoup
pensez vous parfois à la famille de
sharon tate par exemple sharon tate  oui est
-ce que tu penses à sa famille ou à
ce qu'ils sont
comment ils se sentent pour toi est-ce que tu y
penses parfois ou ou tu ne le
fais pas  les sentiments que
tous les sentiments qu'il y a
bien je veux dire ressentez-vous de la sympathie pour
eux pourquoi bien sûr que j'ai tout mais
mais vous ne regrettez toujours rien que
voulez-vous dire regretter voir leurs mots ne correspondent pas
dans nos réalités  ils ne regrettent pas
quand quelque chose est fait  e c'est fait comment tu
vas le regretter je ne ferais jamais
rien que j'allais regretter
mais on dirait que tu ne peux pas te mettre dans la
tête que je n'ai jamais rien fait
je n'ai jamais tué personne
je n'ai jamais ordonné de tuer quelqu'un
je dis juste à tout le monde  la même chose je
te dirais tu fais ce que tu penses être
juste
tu fais ce que ton amour te dit
ils disent demande moi qu'est ce qu'on fait pourquoi demande moi
quoi faire qui suis je pour savoir
quoi faire
je ne sais pas  rien de plus que
n'importe qui d'autre je suis juste un autre gars mais je
suis au plus bas je n'ai personne
vers qui puis-je me tourner vers qui puis-je
aller demander je n'ai pas de père et de mère
je n'ai pas de parents à qui
je peux aller je ne peux aller chez personne
je dois me tenir debout par moi-même
donc tu ne te sens aucune responsabilité dans
ce qui s'est passé il y a 20 ans est-ce que je me sens
responsable de tout ce qui
se passe
une seconde était
et ils m'ont envoyé à l'école de réforme
alors je vais à l'école de réforme pendant 10 ans dans
10 ans et je repars et je
retourne dans  le quartier et je rentre
et je fais rebondir la balle tu sais
et je tombe dans le noir
tous les enfants repartent
alors je vole le flic et je prends une arme et je
vole un tas de gens et je retourne en
prison parce que la prison est ma maison
Noël est  où j'habite la prison c'est
là où je suis la zone homeboy c'est là que mon
âme est mon cœur est
c'est juste un prisonnier comme les autres oui
et je pense que vous avez euh des prisonniers
qui sont bien plus dangereux que lui c'est
sûr qu'on a des détenus  qui ont
commis
des crimes pires que ceux de Manson, mais
ils ne sont tout simplement pas aussi infâmes
que Manson,
ils ont tué plus de personnes que les hommes de
la famille,
mais les noms des personnes
qu'ils étaient n'étaient pas
des personnes célèbres,
donc
ils ne le sont pas  connu mais il y a plus de
gens dangereux que d'hommes manson n'est pas
dangereux
il n'est pas dangereux du tout
je veux dire
qu'est ce que tu penses de lui
je ne sais pas c'est juste c'est un petit
vieux c'est seulement il n'a que cinq deux environ
ta taille
il est un peu  filé tu sais qu'il est un
peu fou
y  ou pense qu'il est fou ouais je pense
qu'il n'a fait aucun des meurtres lui-même
prend watson je l'ai rencontré dans 87 cmc une autre
prison dans le sud et il n'est pas rien
il a fait tout le meurtre réel
il est juste qu'il se cache derrière la bible
je veux un  libération de mon agent
tu ne m'impressionnes pas vraiment
[Musique]
mais comment
il reste pour lui
tu ne traînes avec aucun des
gars
il ne parle à personne
tu as toujours ta croix sur ton
front puis-je le voir  pouvez-vous me rappeler
ce que cela signifie que
les nazis sont morts
mais que beaucoup d'autres personnes sont mortes aussi
mais parce que vous avez cette croix sur le
front peut-être que vous n'aimez pas les
juifs non non non non non toute personne qui
me connaît sait mieux que ça
je  ne déteste personne
je m'aime
et je suis
accompli
tu es comme toi et tu es tout le monde
[Musique]